we're here at CES digital experience
which is a preview of some of the cool
stuff being unveiled at the show this
year we're at the parrot booth you
remember parrot from last year when they
unveiled the AR Drone which is a
remote-controlled quadcopter they're
back this year with the ar.drone 2.0
which is an updated version there's an
outdoor model in an indoor model the
indoor model has some rubber guards
around the propellers and both of these
have HD video cameras in them so you can
record Birds Eye views of wherever you
fly the drone you fly these by using an
app on a mobile device and iPad and
Android phone and iPhone and simply tilt
the phone around to make a go where you
want to you can watch the video feed on
your device while you're flying it and
these are only 299 dollars each and
they'll be out this spring